gary recently moved he sold 2 000 pieces
of vinyl and he kept 200. who'd you let
go gary what was the big uh most of it
well i mean i kept a lot of the box sets
i kept most of the springsteen i had a
bunch of autograph stuff and
um let her go but i also had a lot of
stuff that that you know
that i really just didn't need and i
just have room for oh i just wondered
where your new listening area is still
working on that nice oh it's exciting
which means wherever mary tells me it
can be and she hasn't decided
she was like well if you sold all the
records you don't really need to bring
like that record player and that amp and
those speakers do you and i'm like no no
and she's like you hardly ever listen to
it i go no i listen to it and then she
thinks it's stupid too she probably does
yeah
gary so dumb just get ready all your
vinyl and just stream and listen to that
serious exam and issues
trying to find a place for that big
console
um the console made it over here but uh
under protest
because my mother's piece and everybody
that comes to the house loves it they go
wow we really love that piece except for
mary gary's considering selling his
jukebox too all the dumb [ __ ] that
gary's bought over the years now he's
selling off to other maniacs so thank
god there are more maniacs what can you
get for your vinyl um it was less than i
thought you sold two thousand pieces as
you call them pieces of vinyl how much
do you get can i ask yeah i think it was
about three thousand dollars oh all
right that's more than i would have
thought you'd get
had some kind of great collection howard
hmm
nobody wants that [ __ ]
no one i bet you the guy said to gary
listen dude i know you think this is
valuable go try and sell it well i think
the problem was i had a lot of the
records in my collection had been in a
flood some years ago so a lot of them
i would say like a third of them were
you know were kind of wrecked so
um
three thousand dollars sounds like a
yeah we're hearing that you made out
like a bandit i think i did excuse me if
you keep a penny uh glued to your
stylist i believe these will play
because they were in a flood
they're rather warped who the hell is
buying his used vinyl his warped vinyl
i spent some time thinking about gary
over vacation i was driving crazy i was
thinking about that time when
he was techno beaver we used to call him
but he was yeah what do you call gadget
gary right that way
yes gary always wants to be a performer
i know that about him
for some reason he became a an expert on
tech
well he was writing for these sort of
online magazines or something no they
were actually in your house robin really
really they were real magazines
yeah and so gary found a hook to get
himself on tv and then geraldo rivera
invited gary on to talk about gadgets he
even introduced me goes this is gadget
gary here to talk about the rollicking
pace of technological change from the
way we watch movies to the way we read
books i'm joined by the cw's gadget gary
he is in reality baba bowie the
executive producer of the howard stern
show there's the expert
i remember i was thinking about gary and
i was like where the [ __ ] does gary come
off being an expert on tech he doesn't i
mean he likes tech but he doesn't know
anything
and then it made me think about the
bigger picture i started to think you
know what all these news shows i watch
when they have experts on i just assume
these guys are experts but now i realize
they're not because they had gary being
the gadget expert because herald was
like hey here's gadget gary and i'm like
people who knew our show knew gadget
gary was [ __ ] but i you know i watch
these new shows and they go out there
who doesn't know and they think gary's
an expert that's what i mean like people
in kansas thought that gary knew what he
was talking about is the ipad another
breakthrough for apple
um i don't know that it's a breakthrough
for them
in fact i think in in a lot of ways it
was a bit of a stumble for them there's
a lot of things that are missing from
the ipad that i hear people talking
about that they say are a deal breaker
but for me i'm trying to figure out well
who's it for in other words if i
here in my pocket have
have an iphone
right
so if i have this the ipad is a bigger
version of this so if i have this why am
i going to pay 800 bucks for that and
another 30 a month if i want to get it
on the 3g network gary was wearing a
spindle necklace while he was on the
show in a lot of ways it was a bit of a
stumble he was looking for an identity
as gadget gary and yeah i may have been
wrong in that clip howard just a little
bit
just a little your gadget gary
you